a batalha todos mais uma escada em minha
vida e eu às vezes brinco que eu já
posso me candidatar a jornalista que
mais sobre escadas no planeta porque os
hubs cadas todos os dias quando chego na
rpc foram 1.480 degraus na romênia para
chegar no castelo do drácula mas 4444
degraus na noruega na maior escada de
madeira do mundo e eu vejo isso como
desafios que simbolizam pra gente
alguns momentos que nós podemos dizer
que são momentos de superação de testar
os limites mas os desafios na minha vida
começaram bastante cedo e eu vou dizer
pra vocês aqui hoje que eu vou contar um
pouco das minhas histórias mas também as
histórias deles porque eu comecei vale
de maria e josé uma dona de casa e um
eletricista da então companhia de força
e luz de são paulo uma família simples
né e depois eu já tinha uma certa
intimidade com o microfone será que
aquilo ali já dizia que eu seria no
futuro a minha mãe me levava pra cantar
em programas infantis de música ali em
londrina
o meu era muito tímida cantava muito
nervosa mente mas eu gostava muito de
cantar mpb hoje o risco um pouco essa
brincadeira nos palcos aqui quando rpc
faz no fim do ano o nosso som de natal é
uma forma também da gente se divertir e
ali quando eu finalmente cheguei na
universidade
antes disso já no ensino médio um
professor meu de língua portuguesa
falava assim olha dos maiores que você
seria uma excelente escritora porque eu
gostava muito de ler e escrever e
escrevia poemas e nós dramatiza vamos os
meus poemas a minha equipe de escola
se o professor fosse você como como
gosta de escrever você seria uma
excelente escritora eu pensava assim mas
o professor não chegasse uma escritora
famosa vai demorar muito e eu preciso
trabalhar preciso ganhar dinheiro mas
ele fosse a está começando aqui na
universidade estadual de londrina o
curso de comunicação social
resolvi arriscar foi o meu primeiro
vestibular sem directora da escola
pública para uma universidade e
finalmente comecei a trabalhar depois já
quase terminando a universidade
eu fui trabalhar na folha de londrina
como estagiária foi minha primeira
experiência foi justamente no jornalismo
impresso e dali pra frente
depois nos primeiros passos na televisão
foi chamada para trabalhar então na tv
coroados o domina hoje rpc também é
porque o grupo todo hoje tem essa marca
rpc vejo ali aquela carinha de menina
segurando o microfone da globo e pra mim
eram esses os primeiros desafios já na
década de 80 eu gostava muito de andar
lá pela cidade de conversar com as
pessoas de ser realmente uma contadora
de histórias como o nosso trabalho
propõe contar histórias em forma de
notícia então essa experiência a gente
foi adquirindo ao longo dos tempos e lá
lidar com gente eu sempre gostei muito
de lidar com gente e quando eu me tornei
professora universitária a primeira
coisa que eu falava para os meus alunos
se vocês gostam de gente vocês estão na
profissão certa porque se não gosta de
lidar com gente não é esse o caminho
olha só o nome comunicação social
nós somos comunicadores sociais nós
temos que saber lidar com as pessoas de
todas as classes sociais
então a gente com essa é meio de nessa
essa veia de contadores de histórias no
dia a dia é que se propõe um desafio
para cada assunto que a gente vai contar
mas como eu trabalhava em
jornal e televisão durante cinco anos eu
tive dois empregos dava conta de tudo
inclusive de casamento de filho um deles
está aqui é emoção lindo que só vendo
eu tive que decidir entre o jornal ou
televisão e já veio uma proposta pra vir
para curitiba porque até então eu era a
única repórter do jornal já era repórter
do jornal nacional que ficava no
interior todos os outros repórteres
ficavam nas capitais
então como repórter do jornal nacional
eu tinha que ficar no que a gente chama
de cabeça de rede em curitiba lá vou eu
o meu chefe na época mandou uma foto de
curitiba três horas da tarde um breu
como a gente teve que esses dias não é
pleno dias em três horas da tarde tudo
escuro ele falou olha só que te espera
mas a gente aceitou também esse desafio
de vir para a capital paranaense
e aqui também essa coisa de lidar com as
pessoas do jeito de lidar a abordagem eu
atribuo muito assim o querer bem das
pessoas em relação ao meu trabalho eu
acredito que uma forma como eu chego nas
pessoas como eu converso com elas de
igual para igual né
nós costumamos dizer que devemos ter
empatia se colocar no lugar do outro eu
sempre coloco qual é a pergunta que a
gente poderia fazer o que eu gostaria de
saber o que eu gostaria de questionar
então e 87 nós vemos de mala cuia e
papagaio periquito e o filho mais velho
depois nasceu o curitibano aqui
mudamos pra curitiba e começamos a fazer
mais matérias no jornal nacional
curitiba como não se apaixonar
eu até pedi licença pro meu colega meu
amigo carlos renato fernandes que é um
senhor fotógrafo que tem um olhar
diferente sobre curitiba
imagina quantas vezes já não fotografou
curitiba já fiz vários livros sobre
curitiba um deles inclusive nós fizemos
roteiros
a cidade e eu sempre costumo ver
curitiba com um olhar diferente
eu adoro mercado municipal gosto de
passar pela rua 15h quando chegou ali na
rua 15 para fazer reportagens sobre
bastante abordado as pessoas querem
tirar fotografia é muito legal assim é
as pessoas me acolhe assim como a cidade
me acolheu os parques maravilhosos temos
mais de vinte e seis parques as praças
né a igreja do rosário é bastante antiga
a história é passeio público agora está
sendo revitalizado a universidade nós
temos aqui a a universidade mais antiga
do brasil da universidade federal do
paraná acredito que muitos aqui já
estudam a a1 estrutural nos prédios a
cidade bem planejada o museu do olho mas
temos também claro os bolsões de pobreza
por onde a gente anda uma gente humilde
trabalhadora ea gente não tem ideia dos
lugares que a gente percorre aí na
periferia e trazer as histórias dessa
gente trazer o bem estar o que pode
melhorar a vida das pessoas é o nosso
desafio diário de viver essa cidade de
viver de forma bastante viva viva cidade
e conhecer também o paraná
eu conheci o paraná na prática a
geografia e ainda tem lugar que eu não
sei onde fica
mas rodei muito esse paranazão é um
estado maravilhoso e também fazendo o
globo repórter esse primeiro globo
repórter foi o acontecimento foi assim
um um marco é um divisor de águas mesmo
eu lembro que aí nessa cena estou com a
bióloga fernanda fernanda braga mas o
repórter cinematográfico andré moreno e
ali a gente está mostrando uma uma marca
do lobo guará a gente foi atrás do lobo
guará era um só quando nós tivemos um
primeiro momento e depois nós
descobrimos uma fazenda vários lobos
guarás foi um momento maravilhoso um
animal ameaçado de extinção aqui no
nosso
depois desse é claro vieram outros lobos
repóteres que nos permitem essa parceria
com a globo
viajar por todo o brasil e até fora do
brasil então eu vou aqui para odiar a
clarice lispector que diz que nunca
deixe de fazer algo de bom que o seu
coração pede o tempo pode passar a
oportunidade também não esqueça que a
meta a gente busca caminho a gente acha
desafio a gente topa vida a gente
enfrenta saudade a gente mata sonho a
gente realiza mas enfrentando os
desafios é aceitando o e tentando
transpor os obstáculos é que a gente vai
ganhando espaço vai vencendo a vida no
dia-a-dia e eu queria então resume um
pouquinho de tudo isso é é do que a vida
me ensina do que a vida me deu eu sou
muito agradecida pelo meu trabalho que
pode me levar por esse mundão de meu
deus
e olha eu sou assim é muito feliz também
porque eu trabalho com profissionais
maravilhosos e a gente sabe que o nosso
trabalho tem que ter qualidade tem que
ter resultado né esse desafio diário de
lidar com gente falar com as pessoas de
entender o que o outro precisa
necessidade que o ser humano tem
no fim de semana passada estava
trabalhando de plantão e chegou uma
informação de que uma senhorinha de 70
anos estava há três dias uma unidade de
saúde
sentada numa cadeira esperando uma vaga
no hospital e nós fomos lá essa missão
lhe foi dada
eu falei que está acontecendo vamos de
alguma forma tentar resolver isso e fui
lá consegui entrar na unidade de saúde e
inclusive mais uma moça passou por perto
assim empurrando uma cadeira de rodas
cia acrescenta ainda a porta aí não me
viu
ela não sabe que a empresa está aqui
dentro e da unidade de saúde
resumo da ópera comecei a conversar com
as enfermeiras
uma eu quero tirar uma foto com seu
outro eu também quero tirar uma foto com
você então tá bom gente tão tirando foto
mas precisa resolver o problema dessa
senhora de uma maca ali eu falei aquela
marca ali porque vocês não acomodam ela
encontra espera a vaga pra ir pro
hospital
a avó pediu autorização para a doutora
foi lá entrou na sala da época a senhora
já estava sendo acomodado na maca e não
demorou 40 minutos a gente já tinha
saído de lá
a filha dela me ligou para dizer que ela
tinha sido encaminhada para o hospital
pra quê isso o ser humano precisa ser
tratado com dignidade e é isso que eu
vejo no dia a dia e que me entrego essas
situações para poder ajudar quando a
gente pode ajudar e não custa nada é uma
questão de humanidade e o trabalho está
intrínseco no trabalho do do jornalista
de fazer com que a sociedade seja melhor
porque quando a gente entra um curso de
comunicação no curso de jornalismo
você vai com idealismo de fazer uma
sociedade melhor e é nisso que a gente
acredita é esse o nosso desafio diário
então vou exibir aqui um vídeo que
resume o que os meus colegas pensam a
meu respeito acho que é tanto mas eu
fiquei muito muito feliz com a homenagem
que eles prestaram quando eu completei
35 anos de televisão gente da produção
esses olhos curiosos já viram de tudo as
cesarianas que nasceram sexto cruz durou
meia hora eu mudar seu e visão de
arquivo 350 870 gramas histórias
comoventes que ela vem contando ao longo
de mais de três décadas de jornalismo
parece uma festa
ó
[Música]
tragédias há um mês esse aqui é um rio
de águas bem tranquilas não se via da
estradinha porque toda essa área
protegida por mata nativa e hoje é esta
a situação acidentes
o acidente que deixou cinco mortos e 13
feridos foi no começo da noite de
domingo o o o paisagens deslumbrantes
este arquipélago é considerado um dos
mais belos lugares da noruega
a paisagem vai se revelando cada vez
mais bonita e que outro lugar teria um
espelho onde a natureza também merece
admiração pelo encontro inesperado com a
vida selvagem
[Música]
por onde essa repórter ainda não andou
ela já cruzou o brasil de ponta a ponta
já atravessou oceanos para chegar aos
lugares mais distantes desse mundão
imenso
o mundão que ela já parecia querer
alcançar desde a primeira vez em que
apareceu na tv de lá pra cá foi
descoberta atrás de descoberta desafio
após desafio
isso vai desafiar os seus limites
[Música]
encontros com tanta gente a esse é o
forte do cinema é de gente que ela gosta
é pelas pessoas que ela faz do
jornalismo uma batalha diária é para as
pessoas que ela encontra que sempre tem
guardado uma palavra generosa um carinho
uma demonstração de firmeza diante
daquilo que vê e naquilo em que acredita
que existe mais igualdade do que
diferenças que preconceito deve ser
tratado com justiça que gente deve ser
tratada com respeito um belo descanso na
rede depois de um passeio depois do
almoço depois do lanche da tarde
é a melhor coisa do que isso um porque é
doce né tem orgulho de ser o que é e
sempre que pode reafirma esse orgulho de
um jeito que olha é de admirar e ela
desperta esse orgulho em cada um que
encontrar porque acredita que a vida
devia ser bem melhores será a velocidade
do balão é super lenda quatro
quilômetros por hora parece nós estamos
parados mas nós estamos aqui
lucinéia novaes felizardo vieira ou
simplesmente dupla quem convivi todos os
dias com esse sorriso grande de uma
alegria que contagia que abraça de
alguém que está sempre por perto
a alternativa de lazer para o
londrinense ainda larga o cabelo foi
mudando
mas esse jeitão de quem saiu de londrina
para ganhar o mundo a esse é o mesmo de
sempre
nessa trajetória onde cada dia é uma
nova notícia ela já colecionou tantas
homenagens tantas conquistas que tantos
prêmios que ironicamente não cabem em
uma reportagem de televisão
a experiência já fez dela a professora
mestre em comunicação e doutora em uma
graduação que dispensa de diploma a
humildade a simplicidade a sabedoria
apenas algumas das muitas virtudes que
fazem dela uma companhia que todos
querem perdulária uma presença
fundamental dentro e fora da redação a
sua obra do cinema é gigante
dificilmente vai caber num livro
até porque você ainda tem muitos
capítulos para escrever
[Música]
querem incluir no próximo capítulo então
essa palestra aqui essa conversa com
vocês aqui no ted não é um grande
desafio que honra e orgulho poder falar
pra vocês e dizer que a vida para quem é
corajoso o suficiente para se arriscar e
humilde o bastante para aprender e eu
ainda tenho muito que aprender
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]